what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it's finally happening a live action
Miles Morales movie now we pretty much
knew this was coming we just didn't
really know when and Sony had yet to
really comment on it yes they have
teased it but now they have officially
confirmed yes yes are in fact working on
a Miles Morales live-action movie right
now they also give us an update about
Spider-Woman and an update about
Spider-Man 4 with Tom Holland and
Zendaya Sony has confirmed this so lots
of crazy big exciting news to talk about
today we'll break down the entire
article so you know exactly what is
happening right now in the spider-verse
and of course that does include the MCU
as well as the Sony spider-verse also
it's the last day of our giveaway if you
want a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items be sure to subscribe and leave a
comment down below we'll pick a random
comment and the winner gets to pick one
item we do this giveaway every month so
if you don't win you'll get another
chance but today is the last day of the
month to enter so today's report is
coming from variety they interviewed the
producers of Spider-Man across the
spider-verse so it doesn't really get
much more official than this variety one
of the biggest Outlets out there
speaking to Sony Executives confirming
Miles Morales is coming in live action
form in fact the title of the article
reads Spider-Man producers tease
live-action Miles Morales movie and
animated Spider-Woman film it's all
happening and just to clarify we are
getting a live-action Spider Woman movie
which is supposed to be coming from
Olivia wild but at the same time Sydney
sweetie is going to be playing
Spider-Woman in The Madam Webb movie so
two live action Spider-Woman so when
they say animated Spider-Woman movie
here it's a completely different film
than either of the other two live action
films and here's how the article starts
off as Spider-Man across the
spider-verse finally hits theaters this
weekend The Producers behind the trilogy
have their attention set on the third
installment next year's beyond the
spider-verse however that's not the only
web slinging project that's on their
minds and that line right there just
gets me super stoked already producer
aviarad teased that moviegoers will see
a Spider Woman movie sooner than you
expect he said cannot tell you yet but
it's coming then producer Amy Pascal who
has been involved with every Spider-Man
film so far goes on to talk about
Spider-Man 4 with Tom Holland and
Zendaya but we'll come back to that in
just a bit we'll first talk about what
Amy Pascal said about a live-action
Miles Morales variety reports producer
Amy Pascal says a Spider Woman and a
live-action Miles Morales movie are in
the works a quote you'll see all of it
it's all happening end quote so that's
pretty straightforward plain and simple
I mean Pasco confirms we will see a live
action Miles Morales movie and she said
it's currently in the works right now so
they've already begun working on it
which means they are probably looking
for who exactly is going to play Miles
Morales the actor that will be the live
action Miles Morales and this begs the
question of is this Miles Morales movie
going to take place inside of the MCU or
is it going to take place inside of
Sony's spider Universe I think a lot of
us really want Miles Morales to be a
part of the MCU and I don't really want
to see them do two Miles Morales movies
I don't want a solo Miles Morales movie
in the Sony spiderverse and then later
on Miles Morales comes into the MCU then
gets his own Solo movie there I think
that will definitely start to confuse
fans especially when so many Spider-Man
characters are appearing in the
spider-verse and also of course we have
our own Spider-Man franchise on the MCU
I think they really need to kind of just
go with one one Miles Morales and one
Universe my only problem with that is
and it's not really a problem but a
concern is that Sony's gonna want miles
for their Universe which I totally
understand they own the rights to it and
Spider-Man into the spider-verse has
been extremely successful and Spider-Man
across the spider-verse is already very
successful itself as well so they're
thinking they could probably make a
live-action movie in kind of the same
manner and that be pretty successful and
based off of how well Spider-Man into
the spider-verse and across spider-verse
did they would probably be right except
their track record for Spider-Man
character movies has not been really
good unless those movies take place
inside of the MCU so basically they need
the help of Marvel Studios so I would
love for this to be just another
Spider-Man deal Tom Holland Spider-Man
is only going to do three more
Spider-Man movies and three more team up
films or projects we know he has three
movies and two movies Avengers King
Dynasty and Secret Wars but we don't
exactly know what the third project is
for that for the group up but it looks
like Tom Holland is going to be done
after Spider-Man 6 so I would love for
miles to be introduced into the MCU
before then and then eventually take on
the mantle of the Spider-Man in the MCU
and they would essentially have the same
success that they did with Tom Holland
Sony could live with that so the
decision that they have to make is do we
have a Miles Morales in our Spider-Man
universe and kind of take that on
ourselves no help from Marvel Studios
and see if we can do it or do we go with
what has been tried and true over the
past few years with Tom Holland
Spider-Man with Captain America Civil
War homecoming far from home and no way
home extremely successful movies that's
the decision that they're going to have
to make hopefully it's in the MCU but
let us know your thoughts about this
what do you think should it be his own
movie in the spider verse over at Sony
or should he be brought into the MCU let
us know now back to what Amy Pascal said
about Spider-Man 4. I know a lot of fans
have been wondering what's the deal with
Spider-Man 4 there haven't been a ton of
updates lately and a lot of people have
been asking well did they even confirm
it well yes actually immediately after
no way home was released Amy Pascal and
Kevin feige president of Marvel Studios
confirmed they're already working on it
they were working on it like a week
after Spider-Man no way home took place
now working on it then probably just
meant brainstorming the next idea for
the next movie but Spider-Man no way
home definitely set up a brand new story
for Peter Parker in the MCU and here's
what she said in this interview with
variety are we going to make another
Spider-Man movie of course we are we're
in the process but the writer strike
nobody is working during the strike
we're all being supporters and whenever
they get themselves together we'll get
started so they did get started but
that's been put on hold due to the
writer strike and good for them for
sticking with them but variety
specifically asked them about the next
movie with Tom Holland and Zendaya and
that was her response seemingly
confirming Zendaya is coming back again
we've heard she is from some insiders
but this is Sony directly confirming hey
we're doing another Spider-Man movie
we're working on it it's paused right
now because of the strike but we are
working on it Tom Holland's coming back
which means they probably did already
renew his contract and Zendaya is coming
back as well no word on Jacob yet though
we really haven't heard anything about
him he did say that he would come back
but right now we haven't really heard
much so we're not sure if we'll see Ned
in the MCU moving forward perhaps he
goes away to a different school perhaps
he comes back and becomes the villain
hobgoblin who knows but a lot of
exciting things are happening right now
in the live-action Spider-Man universe
or both Universe we don't know where
miles is gonna be again let us know down
below and let us know how excited you
are for Spider-Man 4 with Tom Holland
and if you have any guesses about what
the plot could be what the story could
be put them down below also thank you to
our patrons that we have so far we super
appreciate your support we are on
patreon now if you want to check it out
and support the channel we'll link it
down below also visiting our website
helps us as well we post every single
day and we have a Discord server now if
you want to check that out don't forget
to follow us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof